ld nouvelle maintenant du porte avions
charles de gaulle en proie à la
contamination du coït 19 sur un peu plus
de 2000 tests réalisés à plus de la
moitié des marins sont positifs 1081
précisément 24 marins sont hospitalisés
dont un en réanimation à dimanche
dernier le porte avions a dû rejoindre
toulon son port d'attache avec deux
semaines d'avancé l'origine de la
contamination est toujours inconnue
la ministre des armées florence parly a
été auditionné hier par l'assemblée
nationale
et elle dit avoir réagi dès qu'elle a
été informée deux enquêtes ont été
ouvertes les responsabilités de cette
épidémie à bord du charles de gaulle
pourront donc être déterminée mais il ne
faut pas céder à la rumeur pour le
général dominique trinquant écoutez le
je pense qu'il faut mettre de côté les
rumeurs il y a deux enquêtes qui sont en
cours une enquête de type médical et une
enquête de type de commandement
l'enquète médical va permettre de
déterminer d'où vient la contagion un
certain nombre d'éléments plaisent pas
penser que c'est pendant l'escale à
brest entre le 13 et le 16 mars et pour
l' enquête de commandement elle va
permettre de terminer déterminer les
responsabilités
la ministre hier a répondu à la
commission en disant que dès qu'elle
avait su c'est à dire des conduits avait
rendu compte
or on lui a rendu compte dès qu'on a su
qu'il y avait des cas à bord et la
demande et à rapatrier le porte avions
le souci principal de l'âme a réuni à
deux soucis principaux le premier c'est
la santé des marins et la deuxième
c'était la continuation de la mission la
mission arrivait à son terme et donc le
retour un peu anticipé n'était pas un
gros sujet mais la santé des marins on
le voit bien aujourd'hui et le sujet
majeur du commandement